-Un petit matin,
..en plein centre de Paris.
Ylan Anoufa à 30 ans,
il est styliste.
Il à un rêve :
devenir l'un des plus gros noms
du prêt-à-porter en France.
Le jeune homme..
..est apparemment
bien connu dans le quartier.
-Je viens, ce soir.
Merci beaucoup.
-Vous connaissez tout le monde,
..ici ?
-Oui, un peu.
On a grandi ici.
-Nous sommes..
..dans le Sentier,
le quartier de la fringue.
Dans ces rues, on est tous
un peu oncles, neveux ou cousins.
Quand on a réussi dans le sentier,
..on ne s'appelle pas
par son prénom,
..mais par le nom de sa marque.
-Ca travaille ?
C'est la Petite Française.
-Vous êtes son oncle ?
-Son cousin par alliance.
Et je travaille ici,
à la Petite Française.
Et je l'ai vu petit comme ça.
-Et je lui cassais les pieds.
Maintenant, c'est lui.
-Même entre concurrents,
on se fait la bise.
-Eh ! Espèce de fou !
C'est Madison.
C'est un petit créateur
sympathique aussi.
Tu fais des choses sympas.
-Des choses sympathiques.
-Il est dans le speed.
-Mais avant de devenir..
..le nouveau Jean-Paul Gaultier,
..Ylan a un petit problème à régler.
Il doit aller chercher d'urgence
des étiquettes pour les vêtements..
..de sa nouvelle collection.
-En espèces,
tu l'as plus vite la marchandise.
En carte bleue,
le temps que... Je ne sais pas.
On le paie en espèces,
si ça rend service aux gens.
-Ici, tout le monde est pressé.
Et pourtant...
-Il n'est pas là !
-Je t'attends devant.
Pas de problème,
je t'attends. A tout de suite.
Comme quoi, dans la vie,
..il faut leur mettre de la pression,
ne pas les lâcher.
Sinon, tu dois attendre.
C'est comme ça.
Dans le Sentier, c'est...
Un mec qui dit "j'arrive",
dans 15mn, il n'est toujours pas là.
15mn, c'est une heure.
-Le fameux Isaac débarque..
..30mn plus tard.
-C'est pas l'original,
mais ça va passer.
Ca fait 120, monsieur.
Merci.
-Je le mets dans l'enveloppe.
Et ça part à la banque.
Avec la facture.
-Pour montrer
que c'est clean, le Sentier.
Ce n'est pas fait à la va-vite.
Quand on paie en espèces,
Il n'y a pas de trafalgar,
..il n'y a pas d'embrouille.
C'est honnête. Tout est honnête.
-Si les 2 hommes jouent autant
la transparence,
..c'est que le quartier à
une réputation sulfureuse.
Le Sentier est l'un..
..des plus petits
quartiers de Paris.
Il s'étend sur à peine 1 km2.
C'est aussi..
..l'un des plus anciens.
Les noms..
..des rues évoquent les vagues..
..d'immigration
qui y ont posé leurs valises..
..depuis un siècle.
Les Juifs et les Arméniens créent..
..les vêtements,
les Turcs tiennent les ateliers..
..de confection, les Pakistanais
poussent les chariots..
..et les Chinois sont
aux machines à coudre.
Toutes ces communautés
ont contribué à faire..
..du Sentier la plaque tournante
du textile made in France.
Kookaï, Naf Naf, Cop. Copine,
ou Morgan sont nées ici.
Mais la réputation du quartier,
..c'est aussi l'argent au noir,
..les ateliers clandestins,
les fausses factures.
Aujourd'hui, la donne a changé.
La crise,
les affaires d'escroquerie..
..et la concurrence chinoise
sont passées par là.
Alors, qui sont les nouveaux rois
du Sentier ? Nous suivons..
..un couple de jeunes chinois,
Hi et Yen, arrivés de Pékin..
..il y a 9 ans.
Ils sont en train de devenir..
..la nouvelle success story
du quartier.
-Ici, tous rêve d'une réussite,
..comme celle de Bhatti
qui a débarqué en France..
..il y a 34 ans.
Il a commencé par pousser..
..des chariots, payé au noir.
Aujourd'hui,
..il est devenu riche
et consul honoraire du Pakistan..
..à Paris, grâce à la fringue.
-Ylan a appris ses valeurs
et ses recettes dans le Sentier.
Il a créé sa propre marque
au nom de sa famille.
Ses arrières-grands-parents..
..étaient des Juifs
de Bab-El-Oued, à Alger.
Ils étaient
dans la confection, les Anoufa.
-On ne sait faire
que du prêt-à-porter,
..que des fringues.
Voilà, tu as un billet
de 500 francs de l'époque.
Mon grand-père m'avait donné
500 F pour ma 1re paye.
A l'époque,
c'était beaucoup d'argents.
Mais je suis nostalgique.
Ca me dit :
"Rappelle-toi des émotions quand
tu avais ce billet la 1re fois.
"Essaie de te les procurer
à chaque fois quand tu descends là,
"..même si c'est un peu le souk".
-Pour se faire connaître,
..il prépare un défilé dans
l'un des quartiers les plus chics..
..de Paris. Mais le Sentier
est-il toujours un eldorado..
..où l'on peut bâtir
une fortune à partir de rien ?
Hi et sa femme Yen
ont tous les deux 30 ans.
Chaque matin, à 9h, ils ouvrent
leur boutique, rue Saint-Denis,
..au meilleur emplacement du quartier.
Ils ont repris ce magasin..
..il y a presque un an.
Ici,
tous les employés sont Chinois,
..tous jeunes et savent tout faire.
Il faut faire les cartons,
..faire l'article...
-Et même le mannequin.
-Leurs clients
viennent du monde entier.
-Moi, j'ai 6 boutiques à Osaka.
-Osaka ?
-Oui, à Osaka..
..et une boutique à Kobe.
-Et vous, vous venez d'où ?
-Du Brésil.
-En moyenne, c'est 15 E
pour une tunique au prix de gros.
-On note ? Ca, c'est M et L ?
-Oui.
-Jamal à une boutique
de vêtements à Thionville.
Avant, il se fournissait chez
les fabricants juifs du quartier,
..mais la plupart ont laissé
la place à leurs concurrents..
..chinois.
-Le service, ça vous convient ?
-Pas du tout. Très désagréable.
Question service,
ils sont nazes.
-Pourquoi ?
-Eux, c'est que le business.
Et ils parlent entres eux
en chinois. Ca, je ne supporte pas.
-Vous ne comprenez pas ?
-Ben non !
-Avant, le Sentier,
c'était pas ça ?
-C'était différent, plus sympathique.
Mais aujourd'hui... Le problème,
c'est qu'ils bouffent tout.
Il y a qu'eux.
C'est ça, le problème.
-C'était quoi avant ?
C'était l'ambiance... ?
-Méditerranéenne.
C'est fini, ça.
[Elles parlent en chinois.]
-Si il vient se fournir ici
chaque semaine,
..c'est que la marque..
..a su marier un prix bas
avec un style tendance.
-C'est vraiment de la copie.
Ils prennent ça
de chez d'autres créateurs.
Ils pompent.
Mais c'est vraiment bien fait.
Et ça se vend rapidement,
parce que le prix est correct.
Quand vous vendez un petit pull à...
Je ne vais pas dire de bêtise.
Par exemple, un comme celui-ci...
Un comme celui-ci,
ça vaut 49 E.
Donc, ça se vend très vite.
Donc, il suffit que ça plaise
un peu, et c'est vendu.
-En réalité, la marque chinoise
s'inspire plutôt..
..qu'elle ne copie. Les modèles,
c'est la patronne qui les dessine.
Dans le bureau de style,
..elle admet qu'elle va chercher..
..ses idées tout simplement
dans les magazines féminins.
Quand elle repère un imprimé..
..qui revient souvent dans
la presse, Yen arrache la page.
-J'ai trouvé quelque chose
d'intéressant.
-Exemple,
..ce pull avec des taches.
-Qui sont les marques
qui vous inspire le plus ?
-Dolce Gabbana...
Missoni...
Et un peu de Chanel.
Un peu de tout.
-Yen dessine des croquis..
..très détaillés
qu'elle envoie ensuite en Chine.
Le couple emploie plus
de 200 personnes sur place.
-Pas facile..
..de gérer une production
à plus de 8 000 km de distance.
Pour s'assurer
que le travail est bien fait,
..il faut appeler tous les jours.
-Bonjour, Mlle. Li.
Pour le modèle Linua,
on va continuer à en commander.
Dans combien de jours
on pourra en recevoir ?
Je sais que c'est
le Nouvel An chinois,
..mais pourrais-t-on l'avoir
avant le 10 ?
Alors, le 15 ?
Vous êtes sûre que ça va arriver
avant la fin du mois ?
Il faut faire le maximum
pour faire avancer les livraisons.
Livrez..
..autant que vous pouvez
dès que possible.
OK. Au revoir.
Au revoir.
-Leur société existe depuis 3 ans,
..elle fait déjà 2 millions d'euros
de chiffres d'affaire.
Le couple ne compte pas
à en rester là.
Un peu plus loin,
..Ylan Anoufa a encore
du chemin à faire.
Il doit absolument finir sa nouvelle
collection de prêt-à-porter,
..il a une vente privée..
..de prévue dans une semaine.
Ces rouleaux de tissus..
..doivent vite être livrés
chez son entrepreneur,
..qui coupe et monte
toute sa collection.
-Ca, c'est pour du pull.
Je fais tout moi-même.
-Le problème, c'est que le quartier
est très exiguë..
..et qu'il stationne
dans un passage pour piétons.
-Excusez-moi,
je vais sortir la voiture.
Je m'en vais.
-Magne-toi !
Rien n'a foutre de ta bagnole.
-Il faut se calmer.
-Je l'emmène à la crèche, putain !
-Moi aussi je m'en fous. Je laisse
la voiture, tu fais comment ?
Eh ben, fais le tour !
-Comment on fait pour passer ?
-Je m'en vais, là.
-Je n'ai jamais vu rentrer
dans une voiture comme ça.
-Comme beaucoup..
..de commerçants du quartier,
Ylan fait fabriquer ses modèles..
..en banlieue parisienne.
Ca lui revient moins cher.
A 20mn en voiture
du centre de Paris,
..c'est entre Pantin
et Aubervilliers..
..que se fabrique
la plupart des vêtements..
..encore produits en région
parisienne. L'entrepreneur d'Ylan..
..est Chinois,
..c'est un ancien
de la Légion étrangère.
Il s'appelle..
..M. Zhong.
-Bonjour, mademoiselle.
-M. Zhong, c'est Léon.
C'est mon légionnaire à moi.
-Le Sentier, c'est le mélange...
-Des nations.
-C'est-à-dire ?
-C'est le mélange des origines,
..de tout.
Aujourd'hui,
je travaille avec M. Zhong,
..qui est mon entrepreneur.
A côté, on a Nikos, qui est Grec,
..et qui coupe
la marchandise pour nous.
Nikos, c'est Nikos,
M. Zhong, c'est M. Zhong.
Entre un Grec, un Juif
et un Chinois, on va les avoir !
-M. Zhong a un argument
commercial,
..sa vitesse de fabrication.
Et Ylan va encore
lui demander l'impossible.
-On est jeudi aujourd'hui, lundi...
-Tout sera sorti.
La robe n'est pas encore finie.
Mais ça va vite.
Ce matin, ça commence.
L'après-midi, c'est fini.
C'est rapide.
Les Chinois au travail,
c'est très rapide.
Il y a pas d'heure,
pas de soir, pas de nuit,
..pas de dimanche.
-On va être en retard.
Vous m'attendez là ?
Et si je montre où se trouve
l'atelier de M. Zhong,
..notre atelier,
car on est ensemble,
..les gens vont venir
et lui demander plus de travail..
..et je ne vais pas réussir
à faire mes petites séries.
Je préfère "motus bouche cousue".
Vivons heureux, vivons caché !
-Dans la confection, chacun est
jaloux de ses petits secrets.
10 mn plus tard,
..Ylan et M. Zhong ressortent
avec 60 de tee-shirts..
..commandés 2 jours plus tôt.
-Voilà la marchandise.
-58. Non, 57, tout ça.
-Je sais pas compter.
-Moi, je compte pour toi.
Je vais noter sur le carnet.
-Je fais 1, 2,
mais je ne sais pas compter.
Je dois apprendre
le français un peu.
Je parle pas bien français.
-Le montage, pour un tee-shirt
comme ça, en moyenne,
..c'est un peu près
dans les 15-17E.
Par tee-shirt, juste pour
le montage, pour le coudre.
Parce qu'il faut retourner
le tee-shirt, c'est compliqué.
Regarde.
Je vais le tourner à l'envers.
Et c'est comme si il était
de l'autre côté.
Il n'y a pas de couture apparente.
Ca veut dire que...
Limite, c'est réversible.
Quand j'ai démandé ça
la 1re fois à M. Zhong,
..il m'a dit en chinois
que j'étais fou.
-Ici, c'est combien par tee-shirt ?
-C'est secret professionnel.
-Selon nos informations,
..les façonniers chinois feraient
fabriquet 2 fois moins cher..
..que dans le Sentier traditionnel.
Retour au centre de Paris.
Ce matin, dans son atelier,
..Ylan doit montrer
ses derniers modèles..
..à quelqu'un dont l'avis
lui est très précieux, sa maman.
-Alors, New York ?
-Je suis quand même
venue te voir.
-Rentre.
-Je t'ai ramené des gâteaux
que j'ai fait moi-même.
-Brigitte vit aux Etats-Unis.
Pour impressionner..
..sa mère, ou peut-être
lui montrer qu'il a changé,
..Ylan s'est inspiré d'elle pour
créer des pièces de sa collection.
-J'ai pensé à toi
quand j'ai fais ça.
Tu te rappelles ?
-Oh là là, Ylan !
Je me souviens !
-J'ai pris sur la photo
quand tu étais à l'Ile Maurice.
Aux Canaries, c'est ça ?
-Non, c'était l'Ile Maurice.
-C'est un peu
le même modèle que t'avais.
J'ai fait la même chose. J'ai pris
la photo, j'ai récupéré un sac.
-Tu as pensé à moi.
-Brigitte, cette robe
vous évoque quoi ?
-C'était une robe que je portais,
..j'adorais,
je la mettait tout le temps.
-J'ai des clients
de cette matière aussi.
Sympathique, hein ?
-Il y a plein de choses
qui reviennent.
Petit, c'était un emmerdeur.
-Et ça, c'est tout
ce qui va arriver en production.
-Il est trop tête en l'air,
..il n'est pas sérieux.
Il fait 3h pour faire une course.
Je suis un peu pareille.
Mais c'est comme ça.
On sait quand il part,
mais jamais quand il rentre.
Personne..
..ne pariait sur lui.
J'ai un frère qui m'a dit..
..qu'il a des mains en or..
..et un gros potentiel.
J'ai le droit
à combien de tee-shirt ?
-Sers-toi.
Shopping is shopping !
-Je vais le garder sur moi.
-Alfred et moi,
on est contents.
-Elle peut être fière de son fils.
Dans quelques semaines,
..il a décidé d'organiser
un défilé de haute couture.
-Merci beaucoup d'être venue.
Et comme on dit, "Playmobil,
en avant les histoires".
-Je t'aime.
-Moi aussi, je t'adore.
Bientôt à Broadway.
-Ce qui fait rêver tous les jeunes
dans le Sentier,
..c'est d'avoir son nom écrit
sur la déventure de son magasin.
Comme Bhatti.
Tout le monde..
..connaît son histoire.
Il a inspiré le personnage..
..tenu par Richard Anconina
dans le film "La vérité si je mens".
Ce Pakistanais a fui son pays
sans un sou il y a 34 ans..
..pour tenter sa chance en France.
Il commence..
..par pousser des chariots
avant de monter lui-même..
..sa propre marque. En quelques
années, il devient millionnaire,
..grâce à une veste noire
en similicuir..
..qui devient un "tube",
comme on dit dans le Sentier.
-Vous en avez vendues combien ?
-Des millions, des millions...
-C'est une imitation de cuir ?
-Tout à fait.
-Selon lui,
..cette veste lui a rapporté
30 millions d'euros.
Aujourd'hui,
Bhatti est une star..
..pour les touristes pakistanais.
Ils veulent voir..
..de près leur compatriote
qui a conquit la France.
-Bhatti a beau être riche
et célèbre,
..il continue de travailler.
Pas question pour lui
de se convertir au "made in china".
Son argument de vente,
c'est le made in Sentier.
Il fait tout fabriquer
près de sa boutique..
..dans un atelir artisanal
tenu par..
..un entrepreneur turc.
-Ca va bien ?
-Il y passe régulièrement.
-Ce qui le préoccupe,
ce n'est pas seulement la qualité.
Il se revendique
respectueux des lois.
Ici, cela n'a pas
toujours été le cas.
-C'est important de voir que ce
n'est pas un atelier clandestin ?
-Faut-il le croire ?
Pas sûr, en effet,
que le quartier ait tant changé.
Il est 10h ce matin-là.
15 policiers font irruptions
au 2e étage..
..d'un immeuble
de la rue Saint-Denis.
Ils sont accompagnés
de 2 agents de l'URSSAF..
..et d'une traductrice chinoise.
A leur tête,
un lieutenant de police.
-Bonjour, monsieur.
C'est un contrôle URSSAF.
-L'enquête a démarré il y a un mois.
Le patron de l'atelier
de confection ferait travailler..
..clandestinement
des Chinois sans papiers.
-Tu peux leur dire "Bonjour
messieurs, bonjour mesdames" ?
[Elle traduit en chinois.]
-Nous allons contrôlé si
toutes les personnes qui sont ici..
..ont le titre de séjour.
-...
-Tout va bien se passer.
-Ces ateliers sont réputés
pour leur cadence..
..de travail infernal.
Ils permettent à certaines marques..
..du Sentier de produire vite
quand un modèle marche bien,
..plutôt que de le faire
fabriquer en Chine.
-Tout le monde reste ici.
-Lui, moi et celle-là.
-Restez là. Pas de problème.
-Faire travailler des clandestins
donne la possibilité..
..aux patrons..
..de les payer moins cher
et d'éviter de payer l'URSSAF.
Le patron turc à l'air embarrassé.
Il y a un problème.
Les factures
et les déclarations URSSAF..
..ne correspondent pas..
..à l'activité de l'atelier.
-Le montant que tu viens..
..il y a une dissimulation
partielle d'activité.
-Pour la police et les agents
de l'URSSAF, l'affaire est claire.
L'entrepreneur déclare moins
de la moitié de son activité..
..à l'administration.
Il y a infraction.
Autre fraude : 4 employés,
3 femmes et un homme,
..n'ont pas leurs papiers en règle.
Le patron essaie de plaider..
..sa bonne foie.
-Selon les policiers,
les gérants de ces ateliers..
..ferment les yeux..
..sur l'authenticité des papiers
qu'on leur présente.
Les clandestins chinois
travaillent vite et bien.
Ils ne comptent pas leurs heures.
-Vous pouvez plus exploiter..
..quelqu'un qui n'a pas
le titre de séjour,
..parce que lui,
il veut juste un peu de cash..
..pour envoyer au pays
ou payer son passeur.
Parfois,
ils sont endettés de 10 000E..
..et ils travaillent 3 ans
comme des esclaves..
..pour pouvoir rester en France.
-Les quatre Chinois sont arrêtés
et placés en garde à vue.
Ils seront fichés et relâchés
dès le lendemain.
Les policiers emmènent également
leurs machines à coudre..
..comme preuve.
-Pourquoi vous emmenez aussi
les machines ?
-C'étaient les machines sur
lesquelles travaillaient ces gens.
-Et ça sert à quoi
de les prendre ?
-Ce sont les pièces à conviction,
c'est leurs outils de travail.
-Le gérant de l'atelier
écopera d'une amande de 23 500E.
Hi, le jeune patron chinois,
ne risque pas d'avoir ce problème.
Il ne fait jamais appel
à des ateliers du Sentier.
Pour faire face à la demande,
il a besoin de réapprovisionner..
..son magasin en permanence,
mais tout vient de Chine.
2 fois par semaine,
il bloque entièrement la rue.
-A l'intérieur du camion,
..plus de 330 cartons
remplis de vêtements,
..20 000 pièces
en provenance de Chine.
-Tu me mets tout ça
dans le stock à l'étage.
Et rien dans la boutique.
-Décharger de la marchandise,
..ici, rien de plus simple.
Des porteurs
pakistanais et indiens..
..attendent pour du travail..
..à tous les coins de rue.
-On n'a jamais vu
embauche plus rapide.
Il n'a même pas parlé salaire
que déjà 6 personnes..
..se mettent au travail.
-Les Pakistanais
déchargent très vite.
Résultat : la rue..
..est encombrée par les cartons.
Les scooters
ne peuvent plus circuler.
Et même les passants sont obligés
de rebrousser chemin.
Le hall d'entrée
devient impraticable..
..et l'ascenseur a été..
..réquisitionné. Les autres
occupants perdent patience.
-Vous avez bloqué les portes.
Moi, je monte.
OK ?
-Madame, vous vivez ici ?
-Je travaille.
-C'est souvent comme ça ?
-2, 3 fois par semaine.
-Comment vous faites ?
-L'ascenseur, je m'en fous,
..mais j'ai même pas accès
aux escaliers. Je travaille..
..dans des bureaux.
Je subis.
-Il faut laisser un passage
pour les gens.
-On ramène le carton.
-Si il y a des clients qui arrivent,
ils ne peuvent pas passer.
On a un magasin, nous, là-haut.
-4 h plus tard, le stock à l'étage
est plein à ras bord.
Il ne reste plus qu'à toute déballer.
-Vous n'êtes pas trop fatigué ?
-Dernier détail,
Hi va devoir payer les porteurs.
Nous quittons la pièce.
-Les Pakistanais veulent 50E
par personne. Hi comptait..
..leur donner..
..30E.
-Finalement, l'affaire
se conclura à 35E.
Il est 22h30.
Ce n'est pas vraiment une heure..
..pour déménager. Pourtant,
c'est ce que fait ce jeune couple.
Ce soir,
..Emeline et Jean-Guillaume
emménagent.
-La journée est dure
entre les livraisons,
..les personnes avec les chariots,
les tissus...
Ce n'est pas pratique,
donc on en profite.
-Autour de leur immeuble,
des ateliers,
..des boutiques textiles..
..et depuis peu de temps,
des logements pour particuliers.
C'est au 4e étage, sans ascenseur.
-Ca passe ?
-Nickel.
-Pour l'occasion, 2 amis
sont venus les aider.
-Super !
-Leur deux-pièces fait 40m2.
Ils le louent..
..1 130E par mois.
Pas très cher quand on tient
à vivre dans le centre de Paris.
D'autant que le quartier
est de plus en plus..
..à la mode.
-Pour le quartier,
ce n'est pas si cher que ça.
-C'est un endroit
où il faut être aujourd'hui ?
Ca devient...
-De plus en plus branché,
..carrément.
-Depuis quelques temps.
Mais c'était quelques rues après.
Vers la rue Montorgeuil,
..c'est ultra bobo,
"branchitude" à fond.
Maintenant,
ça se décale dans le Sentier.
C'est juste à côté,
et on le voit dans la population.
Là, il y a énormément
de petit bobos...
-Des jeunes couples qui emménagent.
C'est chouette.
C'est agréable.
-La rue Montorgeuil fait
la réputation du quartier.
Une rue piétonne devenue
une des plus grosses..
..concentration de bar branché
de Paris.
Le Sentier est à 2 pas
au bout de la rue.
Cela attire..
..les nouveaux locataires..
..et désormais,
les investisseurs immobiliers.
C'est le cas d'André, à gauche.
Pendant 25 ans,
il a travaillé dans le textile.
Il se reconvertit
dans l'immobilier..
..et il a pensé à tout.
-Ma laverie.
Une de mes laveries.
Qui était avant
un magasin de confection.
On l'a ouverte il y a un mois.
Elle est déjà un peu taguée.
Sympa.
On a fait une laverie en bas,
à la place du magasin.
Et au-dessus, c'est
des appartements à la location.
-Cet immeuble était une entreprise
textile. Avec un associé,
..il en a fait des logements
du studio au trois-pièces.
-Cette mutation des magasins
de confection et des ateliers..
..en habitations fait
que la population ici..
..s'est multipliée par 4 ou 6.
-André scrute
la moindre liquidation d'entreprise,
..car il faut être le premier.
En un an, les prix ont flambé..
..de 20%. D'autres veulent
faire des coups immobiliers.
-Voyez, par exemple,
ce bar, là,
..le bar à vin était avant
un magazine de prêt-à-porter.
Il a ouvert depuis 2 mois en bar.
Il a fait de beaux travaux.
Il y a du monde.
Ca bouge beaucoup au quotidien.
Tu viens dans 15 jours :
"Oh, celui-là a ouvert,
celui-là a changé."
Celui-là est en travaux.
Ici il y a "à louer".
Il y en a plein.
Ca bouge au quotidien.
-Aujourd'hui, André a même
décidé de vivre dans le Sentier.
Il a appelé un architecte
d'intérieur pour refaire..
..une grande surface qu'il vient
d'acheter. Il a divorcé,
..et il veut pouvoir y accueillir
ses trois enfants.
Il y a beaucoup de travaux
à prévoir.
-Ici, c'est un atelier
typique du Sentier.
Tables de coupes pour les modèles,
machines à coudre pour monter..
..les modèles ou les séries.
-Derrière vous, c'était quoi ?
-Une table pour préparer..
..les modèles.
-Son 116m2
lui a coûté 600 000E.
Ailleurs, dans Paris,
ça lui aurait coûté..
..le double. Pour le transformer
en loft, il y en a pour 150 000E..
..de travaux.
André a acheté dans l'une..
..des dernières rues où il y a
quelques bonnes affaires à saisir,
..à 2 mn à pied
de la fameuse rue Montorgeuil.
-J'ai attrapé le dernier métro
sur cette rue.
-André compte emménager
avant l'été.
-Il faudrait que vous
me donniez les photos.
-Le problème,
le voisinage est aussi source..
..de désagrément. La rue
Saint-Denis, au coeur du Sentier,
..est un des lieux historiques
de la prostitution..
..parisienne. Le jour,
..les habituées du quartier.
Elles sont une centaine
à battre..
..le pavé au pied des immeubles
où elles possèdent un studio.
La police les laisse tranquille.
Mais à la nuit tombée,
pour nombre de riverains,
..cette activité devient
une véritable nuisance.
Cet habitant s'est installé
dans le quartier..
..il y a quelques mois.
Ce jeune célibataire y a acheté..
..un studio de 40 m2 pour 300 000E.
-Je suis arrivé ici
en mois de juin dernier.
On est bien, ici.
-L'intérieur est très agréable,
la vue, un peu moins.
-Je vais vous montrer ce qui se
passe sous ma fenêtre le soir.
Ca commence vers 21h.
Et le gros,
à partir de 1h ou 2h du matin.
-Juste en bas de chez lui,
d'autres jeunes femmes..
..font concurrences
avec des méthodes moins discrètes.
Plusieurs dizaines d'entre elles
opèrent dans les halls d'immeuble,
..dans les cages d'escaliers,
et parfois dans la rue.
-Le mec avec la casquette
est rentré dans les halls.
(Il est en train
de se le faire dehors.)
-Ce genre de scène arrive
toutes les nuits, jusqu'à l'aube.
Cet autre riverain..
..habite l'un des passages privés
de la rue Saint-Denis.
Le matin, il inspecte
la cour de son immeuble.
-Je regarde ça, par exemple.
C'est-à-dire les préservatifs,
que vous voyez là.
Une des riveraines qui,
la semaine dernière,
..se promenait
avec son enfant.
Et le gamin a attrapé
un préservatif usagé,
..il l'a pris pour un ballon,
et il a soufflé dedans.
Donc, voilà.
La personne est allée
porter plainte.
C'est ce genre de choses
qui sont en plein Paris.
Et c'est inadmissible.
C'est les capotes, les Kleenex.
-200 personnes vivent ici,
..dont des familles avec enfants.
-Meilleur voeux.
-Plein de bonne choses.
Tu as vu ?
-Ben oui, comme d'hab.
C'est notre quotidien du matin.
-Il y en a 2 autres là-bas.
-J'en ai marre de vivre dans un
endroit qui était plutôt agréable..
..et qui devient presque insalubre.
On a des grandes poubelles.
Elles se font un petit abri,
..elles se mettent derrière.
-Le passage privé est pourtant
protégé par une grille verrouillée,
..mais les jeunes femmes trouvent
toujours le moyen de se faufiler.
-Quand on rentrait par la porte,
elles bloquaient derrière nous..
..pour pouvoir laisser la porte
ouverte en s'enfiler dans la cour.
-J'ai eu l'occasion de m'engueuler
avec une ou deux..
..qui bloquaient la grille,
en lui disant que j'étais chez moi.
Je me suis fais traiter
de tous les noms.
-Moi, j'ai même étais menacée.
-Menacée comment ?
-Comme ça.
J'essayais de les faire déloger
en lui disant "dégage".
-Les riverains ont beau porter
plainte, rien n'y fait.
Alors ce soir, ils ont décidé
de passer à l'action.
Mairie du 2e arrondissement.
Six d'entres eux..
..ont décidé de se rendre..
..au conseil de quartier
pour interpeller..
..les pouvoirs publics.
-Je me suis fait insultée
et menacée mardi soir..
..en rentrant de mon cour de sport
à 22h.
Je pense que ce soit..
..ou la mairie, vous les adjoints,
ou le commissaire,
..vous ne prenez pas le problème
au sérieux.
-Une conseillère d'arrondissement
essaie de réagir aux critiques.
-La prostitution..
..a rarement trouvé
des solutions totales.
-Faut-il engager
des milices privées ?
-C'est une bonne question.
-Mais si personne..
..ne pose la question ?
Faut-il descendre
et de me fritter avec elles ?
Elles sont d'un agressif.
-Je ne pense pas non plus.
-Alors, c'est quoi la solution ?
-Je n'en vois pas.
-Eh ben, tans mieux.
On va déménager et faire une zone
de non-droit sur 200 ou 500 m.
Et les gens vont déménager..
..car la mairie, la police et
la politique ne peuvent rien faire.
-Au mieux,
on va déplacer le problème..
..dans l'arrondissement d'à côté.
Ce n'est pas une bonne solution.
Mais les réseaux mafieux, on n'est
pas armés pour ça non plus.
-La police fera
une importante opération..
..quelques semaines plus tard.
Après une garde à vue,
..les prostituées sont revenues
sur le trottoir dès le lendemain.
Retour avec Hi et Yen,
les jeunes patrons chinois.
Désormais, leur boutique
ne leur suffit plus.
Ils misent sur Internet pour vendre
leurs produits aux grossistes.
Tous les 15 jours,
il faut alimenter..
..le site Web en photos
des nouveaux modèles.
Les prises de vues ont lieu
à Aubervilliers, où se trouve..
..la plus grosse plate-forme
en Europe du textile chinois.
Dans l'un des dépôts,
..une société chinoise se charge
de faire les catalogues photos..
..pour la plupart d'entre eux.
Hi et Yen essaient de faire
travailler la communauté avant tout.
Tous sont Chinois,
saut le mannequin.
Une jolie blonde,
c'est mieux pour les ventes.
-Tu peux harmoniser les pommettes ?
Elles ne sont pas bien maquillées.
-OK, OK.
-La jeune femme,
..payée 300E la journée, va en
filer une centaine de vêtements..
..en quelques heures.
Les photos seront en ligne..
..quelques jours plus tard.
-Dans quelques mois, Hi et Yen..
..devraient ouvrir leur première
boutique de détail..
..en dehors du Sentier. Ils visent
un quartier huppé de Paris.
Bhatti, lui, s'évade du quartier
dès qu'il le peut.
Avec le succès, il a pris goût..
..aux arrondissements chics.
-Ce soir, il va prendre un verre
avec l'une de ses amies,
..dans un palace
de la place Vendôme.
-M. Bhatti, vous allez bien ?
-C'est la célèbre..
..aristocrate mondaine,
Hermine de Clermont-Tonnerre.
-Hello !
-Ca va ?
-Bhatti est un habitué des lieux.
Ici, tout le monde le connaît.
-Ca va bien ?
-M. Bhatti, vous allez bien ?
-L'homme aime s'afficher
avec les jolies femmes.
Hermine est un peu son professeur
de bonnes manières.
-Je ne sais pas.
-Si, beaucoup de choses.
-Quand je l'ai connu,
il ne mangeais pas avec les doigts.
Il avait de bonnes bases.
-C'est notamment
Hermine de Clermont-Tonnerre..
..qui l'a introduit
dans la jet-set.
-Sauf l'accent.
L'accent est bien resté pakistanais.
Parfois, on a besoin de décodeur.
Je ne comprends pas la moitié..
..de ce que tu viens de me raconter.
Au bout de 15 ans d'amitié.
-Ca c'est charme.
-"Ca c'est charme", vous voyez ?
C'est "Le" charme.
Il y a du boulot,
je vous le dis !
Ah, mon Bhatti...
-Ylan veut se faire un nom.
Dans quelques jours,
il doit présenter..
..sa nouvelle collection
de vêtements haute couture.
Pour l'instant, il a du mal
à joindre les deux bouts..
..et il aurait bien besoin
de trouver un investisseur.
Ce matin, il tombe
sur un ami d'enfance..
..qui a fait fortune.
-Je te donne une invitation ?
Les lumières c'est gratuit,
les mannequins aussi...
-L'ami semble intéressé.
-Les limousines c'est gratuit.
-OK, tu sais faire le relationnel.
-J'ai besoin de quelqu'un
qui est toujours là avec moi.
-A part ça ?
-Un peu d'oseille.
-Combien ?
-C'est à toi de chiffrer.
-500 000 ? Un million ?
-Les chiffres valsent.
Pas sûr que l'investisseur
soit au rendez-vous,
..mais dans le Sentier,
tout le monde a le droit de rêver.
-Il conduit en jet.
Lui, il ne conduit pas.
Jamais.
Il ne fait rien à part
se détendre et parler au téléphone.
-Il a un jet ?
-Bien sûr.
Lui, il a un jet, un hélico...
Il est bourré.
-15 jours plus tard,
..Ylan doit présenter
sa collection de vêtements..
..haute couture, à 2 pas des
Champs-Elysées, loin du Sentier.
-Le Sentier, c'est le Sentier.
Ici, c'est ici.
-C'est quoi la différence ?
-Il n'y a aucune différence,
..il n'y a aucun rapport...
Tu ne mélanges pas
les torchons et les serviettes.
Si tu es dans les serviettes,
le Sentier c'est sur le torchon.
-Vous ne reniez pas vos origines ?
-Non, tu viens d'où tu viens.
Après, à toi de savoir évoluer.
-Il a réussi à se faire prêter
une galerie d'art..
..sur la très chic avenue Matignon.
Pour décorer les lieux,
..il apporte des sculptures
qu'il a créées lui-même.
Il a aussi réussi à mobiliser
20 personnes autour de lui.
-Je compte sur vous pour épauler,
..pour montrer si le pied
n'est pas assez haut.
Il faut qu'on s'entraide.
-Maquilleurs,
coiffeurs et mannequins,
..tous sont venus..
..travailler gratuitement,
par amitié pour Ylan.
-Cyrielle numéro 1,
Cyrielle numéro 2 !
Mettez-vous en ligne comme ça.
On va se mettre bien en place.
[Musique forte.]
Regardez comment je fais.
-Pour l'occasion,
Ylan s'improvise chorégraphe.
-Tu ouvres le rideau...
Tu te mets bien devant comme ça.
Tu comptes 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
Et là, tu danses.
Stop !
-Le jeune couturier..
..compte même faire venir
des célébrités à son défilé.
C'est notamment Hugo,
son stagiaire, qui s'en charge.
-J'ai Senna, de "Secret Story",
qui vient avec son agent.
J'ai Sheryfa Luna.
J'ai des personnes de TF1.
[Sonnerie.]
Pardon.
-Il espérait aussi la présence
de Jean-Paul Belmondo,
..mais là, mauvaise nouvelle.
-Il va être déçu.
-Quoi ? Zéro pointé ?
-Je n'ai pas pu ramener Belmondo.
-Tu as zéro pointé.
-Comment ça ?
-On avait dit que tu devais courir..
..tout autour de Paris,
sur le périphérique, à pied.
-300 invités sont attendus,
mais à 30 mn du début..
..du défilé, aucune star
n'a encore foulé..
..le tapis rouge. Le stagiaire
d'Ylan relance ses contacts.
-A 45, vous serez là ?
OK. Ben, prions Dieu, alors.
Vous me tenez au courant ?
Merci beaucoup.
-C'est toi qui gère les invités ?
-Oui.
-Tout ça, ce sont des gens assis ?
-Non, c'est tous les gens..
..qui sont confirmés.
-La logistique a quelques ratés,
..mais pas de quoi faire perdre
à Ylan son sens de l'humour.
Il avait réussi à se faire prêter
des voitures de luxe,
..mais elles sont restées
en stationnement.
-On a 2 limousines,
y a personne qu'a été cherché.
On a juste les voitures devant.
Le plus grand mytho de la planète.
On avait des limousines..
..et il n'y a pas une star
qui vienne dedans.
-Finalement, le défilé attire..
..plus de monde que prévu.
Et pas n'importe qui :
il y a sa grand-mère et son père.
Ils n'auraient manqué ça
pour rien au monde.
Et les people sont au rendez-vous.
La chanteuse Sheryfa Luna,
..un des frères Bogdanov,
des vedettes..
..de la téléréalité..
..et une star de X.
-Attrapez-la, attrapez-la !
Voilà !
-OUAIS !
-Tout le monde est là,
..les photos sont faites,
..le défilé peut enfin commencer.
C'est la 1re fois que ces robes..
..dessinées et cousues à la main
par Ylan, défilent.
-Allez, elle vous attend !
-Ylan fait tout comme les grands :
à la fin du défilé,
il y a une robe de mariée.
Comme tous les stylistes du Sentier,
..Ylan ne rêve que d'une chose :
le quitter définitivement.
-Merci à tous.
Bon, moi, je m'arrache !
-Cela voudra dire..
..qu'il s'est fait un nom.